entschuldigung können sie mir helfen
ja sicher wie kann ich ihnen helfen
ich suche eine tankstelle
wissen sie wo es hier in der nähe eine
tankstelle gibt wissen sie wo es hier in
der nähe eine tankstelle gibt ja sicher
fahren sie gerade aus
ja sicher fahren sie gerade aus
dann bei der nächsten kreuzung biegen
sie rechts ab dann bei der nächsten
kreuzung biegen sie rechts ab nach 500
metern kommen sie dann zu einer
tankstelle nach 500 metern kommen sie
dann zu einer tankstelle
ich danke ihnen für die hilfe ich danke
ihnen für die hilfe
entschuldigung wissen sie wo hier in der
nähe eine bank ist
biegen sie gleich bei der ampel nach
links abbiegen sie gleich bei der ampel
nach links ab dann fahren sie bis zur
ida straße weiter dann fahren sie bis
zur ihrer straße weiter dort gibt es
parkplätze vor dem einkaufszentrum
dort gibt es parkplätze vor dem
einkaufszentrum im einkaufszentrum gibt
es eine bank
im einkaufszentrum gibt es eine bank tut
mir leid ich weiß es nicht tut mir leid
ich weiß es nicht tut mir leid ich habe
keine ahnung wo hier eine bank sein
könnte
tut mir leid ich habe keine ahnung wo
hier eine bank sein könnte
tut mir leid ich kann ihnen nicht helfen
ich bin nicht von hier
weißt du bis wann die post geöffnet ist
ja sie ist bis 18 uhr 30 geöffnet
das schaffe ich nicht das schaffe ich
nicht kannst du bitte für mich dieses
paket zur post bringen kannst du bitte
für mich dieses paket zur post bringen
ich muss es heute noch meinem chef
schicken
weißt du wann die post schließt weißt du
wann die post schließt nein schau doch
im internet nach nein schau doch im
internet nach
weißt du ob der kiosk auch batterien
verkauft
nein aber wir haben noch welcher in der
schublade im büro nein aber wir haben
noch welcher in der schublade im büro
paul kannst du mir bitte helfen
ja sicher wie kann ich dir helfen
ich muss zur schule
[Musik]
wir schreiben heute eine prüfung
ich bin knapp dran
ich bin knapp dran kannst du mich bitte
mit dem auto zur schule fahren kannst du
mich bitte mit dem auto zur schule
fahren
jetzt gibt es viel verkehr jetzt gibt es
viel verkehr
[Musik]
nimm doch das velo nimm doch das velo
mit dem velo kommst du schneller zur
schule mit dem velo kommst du schneller
zur schule
was sollen wir heute abend essen was
sollen wir heute abend essen
magst du fisch magst du fisch fisch
finde ich super
ja ich finde ich super
dazu machen wir noch kartoffeln und
einen salat dazu machen wir noch
kartoffeln und einen salat
warum ist diana gestresst warum ist jana
gestresst weil sie morgen eine prüfung
schreiben muss
weil sie morgen eine prüfung schreiben
muss
weil sie viel arbeiten muss weil sie
viel arbeiten muss
weil sie mit ihrem freund gestritten hat
warum ist ahmed glücklich
warum ist ahmed glücklich weil er eine
neue freundin hat weil er eine neue
freundin hat
weil er das abitur bestanden hat
weil er im lotto gewonnen hat
weil er im lotto gewonnen hat warum hast
du keine zeit
warum hast du keine zeit weil ich für
die prüfung lernen muss
weil ich für die prüfung lernen muss
weil ich heute länger arbeiten muss
weil ich heute länger arbeiten muss weil
freunde zu uns zum abendessen kommen
weil freunde zu uns zum abendessen
kommen
warum lernst du deutsch warum lernst du
deutsch
[Musik]
weil ich in deutschland arbeiten möchte
weil ich einen job finden möchte
weil ich einen job finden möchte weil
das die landessprache in österreich ist
weil das die landessprache in österreich
ist
warum bist du mit warum bist du müde
weil ich gestern nicht einschlafen
konnte
[Musik]
weil ich viel gearbeitet habe weil ich
viel gearbeitet habe
weil wir gestern gefeiert haben weil wir
gestern gefeiert haben
gefällt dir die musik gefällt dir die
musik ja sie gefällt mir sehr gut
ja sie gefällt mir sehr gut
nein sie gefällt mir nicht
sie ist mir zu schnell sie ist mir zu
schnell
ich höre lieber ruhigere musik
kannst du mir bitte dein
die geben kannst du mir bitte dein handy
geben
kannst du mir bitte dein handy ausleihen
ich habe keinen akku mehr
ich habe mein handy zu hause vergessen
ja sicher hier ist mein handy ja sicher
hier ist mein handy
nein ich gebe dir mein handy nicht
kannst du mir sagen wohin du gehst
ich gehe mit freunden in den park ich
gehe mit freunden in den park
was macht ihr im park was macht ihr im
park
wir treffen uns und trinken einen eistee
ihr trinkt eistee ihr trinkt ice t
ich glaube dir nicht er trinkt sicher
bier
ich glaube dir nicht ihr trinkt sicher
wann kommst du zurück nach hause
so um 23 uhr so um 23 uhr um punkt 23
uhr bist du zurück
um punkt 23 uhr bist du zurück
verspätete ich nicht verspätet sich
nicht sonst darfst du das nächste mal
nicht mehr raus sonst darfst du das
nächste mal nicht mehr raus möchtest du
noch weitere videos sehen dann abonniere
unseren kanal jeden sonntag ein neues
video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video